hey youtubers it's Charlie oh my god
everything looks different I thought
it'd be fun to do a video just from a
different perspective so let me know if
you like it this way but since we've had
a lot of time to think about Legend of
Korra book - I thought it'd be fun to
start doing some bonus videos so this
will be my top 10 moments from book -
it'll be a mixture of funny and oh my
god left turns next week I'll be doing a
video for the top 10 Last Airbender
characters that we want to see comeback
in book 3 so be sure and subscribe to
get that video - so here are my top 10
moments from Legend of Korra book to
number 10 spirits everywhere the reason
this is such a big deal is because it's
such a huge reversal of everything that
avatar wanted Korra opened the spirit
portals and they're open for good now
which means that spirits are roaming
everywhere everywhere in your backyard
they didn't go into it and too great of
a detail but remember how during avatar
wants time spirits could inhabit
people's bodies and corrupt them that
will probably start happening again now
number 9 core learns to energy Bend so
the reason this is such a big deal is
because so few people know how to energy
been in fact almost nobody does Aang
only learned how to do it with the help
of the lion turtle he probably would've
gotten there on his own because remember
he was a much younger avatar than Korres
it'll be interesting to see in book 3 if
she uses energy bending a lot more than
her regular bending just because it is
so special
number 8 avatar aang was not a great dad
so Bumi kya and Tenzin all talk about
their own experiences with Eng while he
was a dad I think a lot of Avatar fans
were a little disappointed to find out
that Aang did not get this perfect happy
ending that we all hoped he would
obviously it wasn't all sunshine for
them and there's a lot of extra
expectations just because they are
children of the Avatar but I think that
we have to take their complaints with a
grain of salt because a lot of children
complain about their parents regardless
of what actually ended up happening
number seven Bolin and Eska and the
death of ships so avatar is basically
killing off teenage romance in book
three I think of all the romances during
book 2 Bolin and Eska was actually the
most interesting or at least the
funniest farewell my Turtledove
personally I wasn't really invested
emotionally and a lot of the romantic
relationships on the show I'm more of a
core fire ferrets shipper at least in
the sense that I wanted to see the fire
ferrets have adventures together and
that didn't really happen as much in
book 2 so I was a little disappointed by
that number 6 return to the library so
of all the places that we return to from
last airbender time this was actually
the most fun since it was in the spirit
world it was actually the upside down
library I don't know quite how it ended
up becoming upside down and how gravity
was kind of impaired inside because all
the books weren't flying off the shelves
but I think we all went a little bit
nanners when we saw the owl in the
trailer for book two number five the
return of Iroh so of all the characters
on Last Airbender that they could bring
back Iroh was one of the biggest and
most satisfying I think we were all kind
of hoping to see Zuko
but seeing Iroh again and seen that
Alice in Wonderland journey that he took
her on was really satisfying and it was
really amazing from this visual sense
obviously because the spirit world is
animated just a little bit differently
from the physical world in Korra the
reason this is really important is
because it lets us know that all
characters can come back as spirits and
talk to Korra so hopefully in book three
we'll actually be seeing more old
characters number four harmonic
convergence so this refers to both the
event and the events immediately
following it harmonic convergence as a
story device was a lot like the comment
during last airbender but from a visual
standpoint it was actually amazing just
to watch spiritual energy just enveloped
the globe a lot of you been asking me if
I think that unalaq will come back in
book three and book four it was kind of
implied that he was vaporized whenever
fatou was destroyed if he does come back
or if he could come back it wouldn't be
for another ten thousand years until
waturi emerges from raava number three
the dark avatar so this is one of the
biggest moments of book 2 previously we
really hadn't thought about the idea of
a negative avatar remember Korra is
supposed to be the one true avatar
remember like I just said vaatu will not
reimburse from raava for another ten
thousand years so we won't see another
dark avatar for another ten thousand
years so obviously that storyline will
not play into book three and before
number two cores cut off from all the
past avatars Korra basically had her
avatar harddrive wiped whenever Rob was
destroyed
even though normally it would have taken
ten thousand years Jinora actually
helped Korra extract raava from vaatu
early she is the avatar again but all
those avatar harddrive files basically
got erased that doesn't mean that they
were destroyed that just means that she
is physically cut off from them so if
she's going to talk to them she has to
travel to them physically wherever they
are in the spirit world and my number
one moment the life and death of avatar
Wan so I think we can all agree the
beginnings of all the avatar series last
airbender legend of korra is actually
one of our favorite moments but the
unique animation style was just amazing
as well as the characters and getting
that extra choral or learning about
raava and vaatu as well as the history
of the line turtles in the world give
the really big thing about this is that
most
shows won't dedicate an entire story arc
to a character that isn't already on the
show so avatar Wan is like a character
that they basically created for this
obviously the first avatar already
existed we just didn't know who he was
but to give him his own two episode
story arc that just focuses on him was a
big gamble and it totally paid off but
like I said my next legend decor video
will be a top 10 list of characters from
Last Airbender that we want to see in
book 3 be sure to subscribe to get that
right now click here to learn all about
book 3 I just did a preview video a
little while ago and click here to get
my full booktube playlists thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight
high fives
[Music]